[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
July 20th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
millions of high-earning Americans who
make so-called catch-up contributions to
their 401K accounts are in line to lose
a popular tax deduction next year
wsj retirement reporter Anne turgusen
joins us so first of all Anne what is a
catch-up contribution and what does it
allow 401k account holders to do so a
catch-up contribution is an extra
contribution that people 50 and older
are allowed to make to their 401ks so
the way it works is this year the IRS
has set a limit of 22 500 that anybody
can contribute to a 401k and for an
employee that's the maximum that you can
contribute but if you're 50 or older you
can actually contribute an extra 7 500
so somebody who's 50 or older can put in
a total of thirty thousand dollars this
year into their 401K thanks to these
catch-up contributions
so how are the rules changing and do
they affect more than just people in
their 50s no the change in the rules
affects people 50 and older who are
making catch-up contributions to their
401K what the new rule says is that if
you are 50 and older and making catch-up
contributions and you earn more than 145
thousand dollars
in the prior year then your catch-up
contribution has to go into a Roth 401k
it can't go into a traditional 401K all
right let's just stop for a moment and
do a little 401K 101 what is a Roth 401k
and how does it differ from a
traditional 401K okay so the way that
the Roth 401k and the traditional 401K
differ is all about tax treatment of
your contributions and tax treatment of
the money that you withdraw in
retirement for example
with a traditional 401K you get a tax
benefit up front the money that you put
in is not taxed in this current year
that you contribute it instead with a
traditional 401K when you take the money
out in retirement you pay income tax
then
a Roth 401k kind of reverses that and
the money that you put into a Roth 401k
is taxed in the current year when you
contribute it but in retirement the
money can come out tax-free so why are
these rules being changed so the reason
why people who are making catch-up
contributions that's people who are 50
and older who have incomes that are
above 145 000 they are being kind of
forced into putting those catch-ups into
a Roth is because that generates income
tax revenue right now and Congress
needed a way to pay for a retirement
bill that passed last December and that
was one of the primary ways that they
used to pay for it will everyone pay
more in taxes on their contributions
under the new rules no the only people
who are going to be paying more in taxes
than they would have otherwise are
people who are 50 and older and are
making catch-up contributions and earn
more than a hundred and forty five
thousand dollars a year those people if
they had preferred or would have opted
or been defaulted into a traditional
401K for those catch-ups
they would have gotten an upfront tax
benefit that they will no longer get and
instead the money will be taxed this
year now financial planners you spoke
with suggest that everyone put money
into a Roth 401k under the new rules why
do they suggest that the general point
that financial planners make these days
is that it's good to have what they call
tax diversification by which they mean
most people can benefit from having some
money in a Roth 401k or a Roth IRA which
is you know a similar type of account so
the idea being that when you're in
retirement
people who have a lot of money in
traditional 401ks once they hit age 73
they have to start taking that money out
that's something that the IRS mandates
it's the law and when they start taking
that money out they owe income tax and
so
if you have been a big saver your whole
life and you've put a lot of money into
a traditional 401K you are going to be
pulling a lot of money out annually and
that could easily get you back into the
same kind of tax bracket that you were
in when you were working so the idea
being that if you have some money in a
Roth you can pull that money out
tax-free and in a year when you say you
need extra money to do something but by
pulling that money out of your
traditional account it's going to push
you into a higher tax bracket instead
you can take the money out of the Roth
you get that tax-free income it doesn't
push you into a higher tax bracket it
can be a very useful tool for tax
planning in retirement and people can
face some decision making when it comes
to estate planning or mapping out their
retirement right so it can be a useful
tax planning tool for people in
retirement but it also the Roth is a far
better asset for your heirs to inherit
than a traditional 401K is the reason
being that with a Roth your heirs will
inherit tax-free money and often when
people inherit money they're often in
their Peak earnings years maybe their
parents die and they're in their 50s and
they're really they're earning
at a level that puts them into a higher
tax bracket and then if they inherit a
traditional 401K they're going to be
required to pull money out of that and
pay taxes at the high rate that they're
in in their Peak years so in contrast if
that same person inherits a Roth that's
tax-free money and they don't have to
pay any income taxes the same as with a
traditional 401K but it's tax-free so it
doesn't cause them to have to pay a huge
amount more in taxes and all the money
is theirs and all the money says all
right that's Wall Street Journal
retirement reporter Anne terguson and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
foreign